esclandre inattendue à l'assemblée
nationale lionnel jospin apostrophe les
députés de l'opposition qui quittent
l'hémicycle
le gouvernement relance les zones
d'éducation prioritaire dans les
banlieues difficiles ces établissements
ne doivent pas se transformer en guide
aux épidémies de gastro entérite dans 12
régions françaises les plus touchées
sont le languedoc-roussillon le centre
et le nord pas de calais la découverte
de las vegas la capitale du jeu
américaine est en plein développement
elles manquent même de main d'oeuvre
pour réaliser des projets hôteliers
gigantesque bo peine 8000 change la
coupe du monde c'est dans six mois mais
déjà les organisateurs s'inquiètent des
supporters de football anglais pour
tenter de les canaliser ils seront
accompagnés par des policiers de
scotland yard
madame monsieur bonsoir l'assemblée
nationale l'a connu cet après midi un de
ses esclandres dont les députés français
ont le secret au lendemain du 100e
anniversaire du célèbre article j'accuse
signe emile zola en faveur du capitaine
dreyfus une question sur une autre
commémoration le 150e anniversaire de
l'abolition des esclavages a mis le feu
aux poudres entre lionel jospin et
l'opposition
en quelques secondes à peine jean
baptiste auprès d'ali i need a eu
quasiment jamais vu à l'assemblée
lionel j'ose pas parler d'histoire et
l'hémicycle s'est embrasée
une question sur l'abolition de
l'esclavagé le premier ministre élargit
sa réponse à la sphère dreyfus et met le
feu aux poudres n'est sûr que la gauche
était pour l'abolition de l'esclavagé
on ne peut pas en dire autant de la
droite on sait
on sait que la dèche on sait que la
gauche était réfusé hard et on sait que
la droite et est antidreyfusard aussitôt
la droite quitte l'hémicycle et le
tumulte ne fait que commencer alors
d'esclaves venus de la nuit de temps
alors
dans les couloirs ensuite la polémique
va succéder à la leçon d'histoire
à le premier ministre s'est visiblement
égaré on peut effectivement j'ai trouvé
des circonstances atténuantes
de plus des nombreux malheurs
là dessus
pas sûr
il a su aussi lieu
le qui détient kirby de portée
le chi
après c'est le tir
historien
monsieur jospin est dans une très
mauvaise passe
les chômeurs
et ils essayent par des manoeuvres
à la fois dérisoire
il est loyal et entouré
ressouder la pauvre majorité plurielle
était aujourd'hui une majorité explosé
lionel jospin avait invoqué gambetta
mort depuis 12 ans au moment de l'
affaire dreyfus philippe séguin le faire
remarquer avec ironie matignon minimise
au fronton de l'assemblée le texte du
j'accuse de zola rappelé aussi les
passions françaises
la violence dans les villes après plus
de quatre heures d'entretiens entre le
chef de l'état et douze maires de villes
moyennes hier à l'elysée tous les
intervenants sont tombés d'accord pour
dire que la réunion avait été très
constructives qu'elle a largement
dépassé les clivages politiques bref
tout le monde était satisfait de cette
rencontre
une autre aura lieu au mois de février
témoignage de deux des invités au
lendemain de cette réunion reportage
patrice anden matthew la citoyenneté au
quotidien le maire rpr de
mantes-la-jolie l'appliquent et la
défend plus que jamais au lendemain de
la rencontre avec jacques chirac
moi je suis convaincu que le fait que le
chef de l'état ait voulu envoyer un
signal fort en disant l'état donc la
nation doit se mobiliser sur ces
problèmes d'insécurité qui pourrissent
la vie quotidienne des français ça va
forcément faire bouger les choses
pour le maire socialiste des mureaux
l'initiative élyséenne s'inscrit dans la
foulée du congrès de villepin ont sacré
il ya trois mois à la sécurité en tout
cas c'est un plus mais attention je dois
dire que de travailler au niveau le plus
élevé de l'état c'est important mais ça
a fait lever aussi un immense espoir
dans la population et ils appartiennent
surtout de ne pas décevoir ses espoirs
espoir dans les quartiers espoir
également dans les mairies ou les élus
rejettent la politique politicienne sur
le dossier de la ville je crois que
effectivement on peut arriver un
consensus qui permettrait de régler les
problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés
en tout cas je le crois mais je le veux
quand vous êtes maire vous êtes de
gauche de droite dans votre politique
fiscale est dans votre politique
budgétaire pour le reste il n'y a pas de
différence quand il faut refaire de
l'éclairage quand il faut construire une
école c'est pas de gauche tous et pas de
droite et sur les problèmes d'insécurité
c'est pas de gauche ou sepa droite c'est
insupportable pour tout le monde
rpr ou socialiste droite ou gauche
d'accord sur les objectifs pas toujours
sur les moyens
l'état ne fonctionne pas bien et nous
avons aussi noté le fait que les textes
quelquefois existait mais n'étaient pas
appliquées c'est le cas par exemple sur
les allocations familiales dont on parle
lorsqu'un enfant ne va pas à l'école
automatiquement les allocations
familiales doivent être suspendues une
autre question qui a été posée par le
président qui était couvre-feu ou pas
couvre-feu a donné lieu à des avis
divers qui est d'avis divers d'ailleurs
qu'il ne venait pas toujours forcément
de clivages politiques mais qui étaient
parfois le reflet de la sensibilité
personnelle de tel ou tel individu le 10
février prochain les 12 maires retourne
à l'elysée et c'est également février
que lionel jospin présentera son projet
sur la ville on sera alors à un mois des
élections régionales
suite à des actes de violence les
chauffeurs d'autobus de lyon ainsi que
ceux de nancy étaient en grève
aujourd'hui
arrêt de travail également à strasbourg
ou 100 % des autobus sont restés au
dépôt jérôme soûlard sylvain gauthier à
pied ou à bicyclette
les strasbourgeois ont dû se passer de
bus et de tramway aujourd'hui une grève
de 24 heures des transports en commun
déclenchée dans huit grandes villes de
l'hexagone pour protester contre les
problèmes d'insécurité agressions et
actes d'incivilité ont toujours ces
dernières semaines c'est vrai la
capitale alsacienne n'a pas été épargné
par exemple pour le mois de décembre
on a eu très agressions physiques 30 qui
jets de pierres et de projectiles dont
certains avec blessés et par moins de
380 incident tout confondu si on englobe
le vandalisme de vols des agressions
verbales extra et pour les chauffeurs la
solution est évidente il faut augmenter
les effectifs d'agents de sécurité
ça nous coûtera peut-être ces violences
là et ça limiterait peut-être aussi les
dégâts
donc une meilleure présence sur le
terrain mais hier présente sur le réseau
ça très rassuré et peut être les
conducteurs et sa peau éviter peut-être
aussi pas mal d'agression unanimité
exceptionnelle sur ses problèmes
d'insécurité car même la direction des
transports à compagnie si les demandes
de ses chauffeurs grévistes
nous comprenons effectivement les
problèmes d'insécurité que rencontre
notre personnel nous sommes solidaires
de notre personnel sur ce sujet on peut
faire quelque chose à condition d'y
mettre les moyens et nous avons essayé
de le faire nous continuons à le faire
cette année
je crois que c'est l'élément le plus
important les emplois jeunes sont là
pour nous y aider
nous aurons donc avec ses 25 personnes
de plus l'an prochain d'autres moyens
encore plus important pour y arriver
demain les bus et tramways devraient
circuler normalement
mais à strasbourg comme ailleurs les
problèmes d'insécurité auront beaucoup
marqué les esprits sans que personne
jusqu'à ce jour n'est trouvé de réelle
solution
ça se voit encore l'arrestation de trois
jeunes gens soupçonnés d'avoir fabriqué
une bombe artisanale qui a explosé
samedi soir devant une école maternelle
faisant des dégâts relativement
important donc autour de cette école
russe c'est toujours dans ce contexte
d'amélioration de la situation dans les
quartiers difficiles que le ministre de
l'éducation scolaire ségolène royal a
présenté aujourd'hui un projet de
relance des zones d'éducation
prioritaire qui ne doivent pas être
considérés comme des ghettos mais plutôt
comme des locomotives a dit le ministre
ces zones d'éducation prioritaire existe
déjà depuis une quinzaine d'années
maintenant
et certaines fonctionnent très bien
comme c'est le cas à ivry sur seine en
banlieue parisienne jean bernard schmidt
à la location chacun dans leur classe
ses professeurs sont chargés de l'aide
au travail personnel deux heures par
semaine en plus des cours habituels
parce que leur collège et placés en zone
d'éducation prioritaire
deux heures pour réapprendre à l'enfant
les bases faire son cartable ou tenir un
cahier de texte nous essayons
d'apprendre aux élèves leur métier
d'élève où sont basés et comme il n'y a
pas de famille pour les aider à
travailler
le professeur principal devient la maman
qui s'occupe des élèves au coeur d'un
quartier fortement touchés par la crise
et le chômage
le collège molière d'ivry sur seine est
classé en zep depuis 1982 ici 85 100 des
élèves sont issus de milieux défavorisés
ce professeur de mathématiques en poste
depuis 30 ans a vécu l'avant et l'après
z
on n'est plus le professeur que le lier
à 20 ou 25 ans venir faire un cours
magistral puissant à lui non on a des
contacts beaucoup plus important avec
les élèves à tous les niveaux on les
retrouve même à certains moments dans
des sos dans l'est ont des soutiens
individualisés pratiquement donc c'est
une nouvelle façon d'enseigner ça c'est
sûr qu'on n'enseigne pas aboli
z comme on pourra enseigner dans un lit
j'ai grandi ces parisiens le classement
en zep c'est aussi pour ces collégiens
un soutien scolaire systématique et plus
d'adultes pour s'occuper d'eux
enseignants assistantes sociales appelés
du contingent ou emplois jeunes les
enseignants et les équipes qui
travaillent à l'est sont constamment
obligés de se remettre en cause
constamment obligé d'inventer des
réponses aux situations auxquelles nous
sommes confrontés quelle qu'elle soit et
c'est ça qui fait que ce quotidien est
extrêmement lourd extrêmement mais aussi
extrêmement riche et aussi j'ai on a de
grandes satisfactions quand on réussit à
z est ici la réussite est au rendez vous
88% du succès au brevet des collèges
bien au delà de la moyenne nationale le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
dominique strauss kahn présentait
aujourd'hui ses voeux il reste optimiste
à propos de la croissance économique de
la france en 1998 autour de 3%
la relance de la consommation intérieure
devrait combler le déficit
d'exploitation en direction de l'asie
notamment pour la première fois de
manière tangible d'ailleurs la crise
financière des pays d'asie du sud-est
fait irruption en france la société sud
coréenne daewoo a décidé de geler pour
une durée indéterminée
son projet d' usine de téléviseurs qui
devait s'installer à thionville
yannick letranchant des ou en lorraine
c'est déjà une réalité des
réfrigérateurs dans la meuse des
téléviseurs en meurthe et moselle
plus de 1000 emplois et ce n'est pas
rien dans une région industrielle
sinistrée mais d où avait promis de
faire plus de s'étendre de s'implanter
encore une usine de verre pour tubes
cathodiques devait être implanté en mars
projets gelés
espoir déçu on a eu tendance à mettre
tous ses oeufs dans le même panier c'est
à dire à tout miser sur la vie sur les
investisseurs étrangers
aujourd'hui on voit bien que cette
politique a des limites donc il faut
probablement diversifier notre politique
d'emploi mars 90 cette poignée de main
officielle entre lorrains et coréen
photo de famille des jours heureux bien
avant la crise en asie une crise
boursière et financière de grande
ampleur d humour voit aujourd'hui ses
investissements à la baisse
le choix stratégique de la mutuelle et a
remis en balance et sur le site en
particulier mais ils m'ont toujours dit
que s'ils s'installaient en france il
s'installerait à thionville fusion des
hommes de parole il y avait 700 nouveaux
emplois à la clé 1 milliard sept
d'investissement le projet d ou à
thionville est pour l'instant gelé pour
une durée indéterminée début de la
négociation salariale dans la fonction
publique le ministre en a appelé à la
responsabilité des partenaires sociaux
expliquant que la priorité irait taux
bas salaires
les chômeurs tente de rester mobilisés
alors que les fonds d'urgence se met en
place dans les préfectures notamment
il prévoit une autre journée d'action
journée prévue pour samedi prochain dans
plusieurs villes de france et à paris
sur l'emploi encore avec le début d'une
campagne de recrutement de la marine
française qui comme l'armée de terre et
de l'air va devenir vous le savez
complètement professionnels 3000
embauches dont 1000 emplois non
spécialisés une campagne dont on sait
déjà qu'elle attirera sans mauvais jeu
de mots plus d'appelés peu d'élus
laurent boussier jean louis brousse elle
est moins de 25 ans du popb bac + 2 la
marine nationale vous assure une
formation d'avenir avec la marine
nationale mets tes disent elles dans
votre avenir
un slogan une campagne de pub et à la
clé 3400 emplois en ces temps de chômage
la marine nationale recrute et veut le
faire savoir
mécanicien radariste commando pilotes en
tout une trentaine de métiers différents
et pour la deuxième année consécutive un
bon millier de postes réservés à des
jeunes sans diplôme et sans emploi
faisant un message parfaitement reçu ce
matin dans les centres de recrutement
ils étaient déjà nombreux à venir
chercher des renseignements il ya une
deuxième branche qui la branche du
service général service général c'est
également ce sont les bâtiments de la
marine nationale à 18 ans anthony a déjà
connu la galère échec scolaire petits
bouts au chômage pour lui ces contrats
marine de deux ans réservé aux sans
diplôme c'est peut-être une vraie chance
de s'en sortir dans les airs gens qui
remplissent un dossier
il explique ses motivations sur la
recherche d'un emploi et j'ai jonglé
entre deux boulots en boulot c'était pas
facile donc je n'ai pas le droit aux
assedic
j'ai rien droit est-ce que la marine
pour vous c'est le grand bond en avant
c'est je pense que ce sera plus pour moi
dans la vie ça sera ce sera je pense que
je pense je fais un nouveau départ là ça
ne venait pas si je suis pris ça serait
vraiment bien
pour la marine nationale plus habitué à
recruter au niveau du bac ou dut bts
il s'agit d'occuper les postes
auparavant tenue par des appelés et de
contribuer à l'effort national contre le
chômage
nous prenons déjà ne peut pas qualifier
pour leur apprends un savoir être une
socialisation dans une société française
nous les prenons pour deux ans dans des
métiers simple mais tout à fait
intéressant au métier embarqués à bord
des bateaux l'année dernière pour un peu
plus de 3000 postes offerts dans la
marine
quinze mille candidats s'étaient
présentés c'est malheureusement la même
chose chaque année ou presque à la même
époque une épidémie de gastro-entérite
traverse la france cette année les
régions les plus touchées il y en a
douze sont le languedoc roussillon le
centre et le nord pas de calais
reportage à lille justement à mourir
patrick bource temps le médecin est venu
en urgence depuis ce matin nathalie se
sent plutôt patrac 12,6 j'ai des nausées
des nausées des douleurs abdominales et
pire soir depuis ce matin c'était
franchement peu parce que franchement
améliorée nausées diarrhées le
diagnostic est rapide gastro entérite
l'ordonance assez simple et généralement
seulement 24 heures voire 36 heures de
revault et de réhydratation donc boire
beaucoup de maîtres l'intestin purple
mangeant peu de carrosserie pas pour
qu'on s'y perd un peu nos menus transit
et tout rentre dans l'ordre dans les 24
ou 36 heures comme chaque hiver après
des fêtes de noël l'épidémie est de
retour ce docteur à soigner jusqu'à
quinze malades par jour la plupart du
temps d'origine virale
la gastro-entérite est très contagieuse
et longtemps absent ou là c'est le
contact avec les mains en fait des
autres toilettes vous l'avez pas les
mains donc vous passez microbes à
quelqu'un d'autre qui autour de vous dès
qu'un premier diarrhée huysman ne savait
les mains après les toilettes
systématiquement pouvoir utiliser le mot
mood javel pour nettoyer cuvette
c'est ici dans ce laboratoire que l'on
recense toutes les épidémies en france
actuellement douze régions sur 22 sont
concernés on est à la deuxième semaine
de l'épidémie
l'épidémie va probablement dur
si c'est comme les autres années quatre
semaines en tout en quatre semaines tout
sera résolu et probablement pratiquement
toutes les régions de france seront
touchés la gastroentérite a encore de
beaux jours devant elle la maladie est
complexe
la probabilité de trouver un vaccin est
quasi nul vous souvenez sans doute de la
commune d'aubry en lorraine dans
certaines habitations se sont
littéralement enfoncé dans le sol à la
suite d' affaissement de terrain
provoqué par les fonds dans
l'effondrement de galeries minières non
loin de là dans la ville de joeuf la
municipalité a décidé de prendre les
devants en plaçant des capteurs d'
alerte au point critique la ville étant
également traversé deux galeries
minières abandonné aux mâles blancs
daniel levy des galeries d'une ancienne
mine de fer qui s'affaisse et en surface
un paysage digne d'un tremblement de
terre
c'était en novembre 96 en quelques
heures plus de 200 habitants de la
colline de vue et se retrouve à l'art
comme le propriétaire de cette maison
obligée de trouver refuge ici chez ses
beaux parents dans une commune voisine à
geof
sauf que les autorités viennent de
placer sous haute surveillance
microsismique à cause des risques
d'effondrement minier une éventualité
que gérard carré garraud prend au
sérieux faut savoir qu'à l'ennoyage de
mines qui serait c'est à dire que l'eau
monte dans les galeries ça crée des
pressions terribles et personne ne peut
dire vraiment ce qui va se passer
donc on a beau prendre toutes les
précautions mais on ne sait pas ce qui
se passe geof dont les mines de fer ont
fait la fortune de la région depuis le
début du siècle avant de fermer les unes
après les autres à partir des années 80
laissant la ville avec un lourd héritage
un sous sol comme un gruyère à 100
mètres de profondeur alors pour écouter
la moindre se poussent en provenance des
mines cinq capteurs comme celui ci
viennent d'être installés une
surveillance de tous les instants le but
prévenir le danger
la présence des deux couches prises dans
le minerai de fer environ 100 mètres de
profondeur sous la ville de jeunes
montrent qu'effectivement si
l'effondrement spontanée devait y avoir
cela pourrait avoir une amplitude en vue
en 30 cm à 40 cm de profondeur au niveau
du désert de surface le maire accuse lui
dit responsabilité des exploitants
miniers qui ont creusé sous des zones
habitées mais pour lui cette
surveillance est plutôt rassurante la
mise en place d'un dispositif qui est
fort intéressant parce que il nous
permet non pas de nier l'existence du
risque mais de prévenir je pense que
c'est un élément positif rassurant pour
la population le contrôle permanent
commencera à partir de vendredi prochain
aucune secousse microsismique ne pourra
leur échapper aux capteurs plusieurs
associations se sont créées en france
pour dire non aux péages des autoroutes
urbain qui traverse les villes donc à
toulouse
leur action a été couronnée de succès
puisque le péage a disparu à lyon le
problème est différent la société qui
gère l'autoroute meinau météo se
retrouve en graves difficultés
financières car les lyonnais boudent ces
10 km d'autoroute qui coûte de même 16
francs didier guyot olivier jacquin
à l'image de ces automobilistes les
lyonnais depuis l'été boycott le nouveau
périphérique nord chaque jour 22 mille
voitures l'empruntent
on est bien loin des 50 à 60 nouveaux
véhicules escompté pour le
concessionnaire le manque à gagner
considérable et à jurbise scandaleux 16
francs pour 10 km plan de circulation
complexe investissements inutiles
les critiques ne manquent pas mais le
contrat signé entre le consortium gouic
dumez et l'ancienne municipalité de
michel noir est là avec nos solides
clause de garantie ou ne dénonce pas un
contrat de concession qui est fait pour
comptant 100 alors se mettre dans la
situation de ceux qui ont à payer les
indemnités
or je sais que faudrait prélever des
impôts sur le kung fu de pouvoir rompre
le contrat raymond barre tente de celui
des moins de trouver une solution
écologistes et associations d'usagers
ont gagné une première bataille devant
la justice les anciennes voies
concurrents du périphérique n'ont pas
été rétrécie trois experts ont également
remis un rapport à la municipalité des
experts qui annonce la faillite
économique du concessionnaire
les opposants au péage se frotte les
mains nous allons encourager dans les
prochains jours tous les lyonnais à
poursuivre leur boycott
c'est le moyen de résistance civique le
plus fort que nous ayons pour combattre
contre ce contrat de concession qu'on a
de tout temps
dénoncé comme étant contraint honteuse
pour notre agglomération et retrouver un
peu de dignité pour notre agglomération
actuellement une baisse des tarifs de
péage est à l'étude mais quelles que
soient les solutions envisagées les
lyonnais aujourd'hui ne peuvent que
regretter et dénoncer cet immense gâchis
de 6 milliards de francs
en belgique le père d'anne marche à
l'une des quatre jeunes filles victimes
du pédophile marc dutroux n'a plus
confiance dans la classe politique de
son pays et la langue décidé aujourd'hui
de créer son propre parti un parti de la
morale
alban nicosie philippe deslandes
reportage paul marchal peut rire de son
effet des caméras par dizaines des
journalistes dans le moindre recoin pas
sûr que même le premier ministre belge
utah tirer davantage sa légitimité
politique à la tête du parti pour une
nouvelle politique il entend la puiser
auprès de cette belgique morale qui
avait défilé massivement en octobre 96
cette marche blanche qui misait
l'émotion d'un peuple face aux martyrs
de ses enfants mais aussi sa méfiance
envers sa classe dirigeants
ce jour-là paul marchal aurait dit à ses
amis son intention d'incarner ce
mouvement
dan et 90,6 que quand le gouvernement ne
fait pas beaucoup on va le faire nous
mêmes et donc un an plus tard ils n'ont
pas réussi à faire quelque chose donc
c'est à nous paul marchal a détaillé cet
après midi son programme protéger les
faibles les victimes de délits les
enfants bien sûr mais aussi dénoncé les
corrompus vise l'état les partis
politiques quelquefois la justice son
approche se veut contestataires mais
selon un sondage neuf pour cent des
belges eux seulement sont convaincus
charge
monsieur marshall oui dans un nouveau
parti oui mais est-ce que ça n'est pas
un peu facile
nous les belges avons besoin d'un
nouveau parti politique mais lui en tant
que personne on est il du succès je ne
sais pas
paul marchal devra donc convaincre là un
peu plus d'un an avant les prochaines
élections il espère que les roues sont
les parents de mélissa très populaire en
belgique le rejoindre dans cette
aventure au procès de maurice papon
aujourd'hui à bordeaux on a abordé la
question de la responsabilité de
l'accusée à propos d'un quatrième
convois de déportés juifs dans lequel
figurait le père du principal accusateur
finalement de l'ancien secrétaire
général de la préfecture de gironde
michèle sites inscrits françois privat
philippe dumas une lettre des autorités
allemandes à la préfecture de la gironde
elle est datée du 19 octobre 1942 et
ordonne l'arrestation de juifs de
nationalité étrangère
c'est pierre garrat chef du bureau des
affaires juives subalterne de maurice
papon qui organise l'opération en
liaison avec les allemands aujourd'hui à
l'audience
maurice pas bon temps d'expliquer les
choses garrett été étouffé par les
allemands toute l'opération a été
commandée encadrée contrôlée par les ss
c'est vraiment l'exécution par la police
française
dans le cas de la convention d'armistice
d'un ordre allemand encadrés par les
allemands contrôlé par les allemands
c'est l'essentiel maurice papon
n'intervienne à aucun moment
garin et le factotum de maurice papon en
tant que chef du service d question de
jours c'est lui qui est l'intercesseur
entre les services des préfectures et
les ss et c'est lui qui y compris autant
dise pas qu'on organise en réalité tout
ce qui est le convoi avant d'être
transféré au camp de mérignac
quarante et une personnes sont arrêtées
par la police française sous contrôle
des allemands dans la nuit du 19 au 20
octobre 1942
parmi elles abraham sit ins qui est sa
fille alice son fils michel est devenu
l'un des principaux accusateurs de
maurice papon
il avait échappé à cette rafle en fuyant
par les toits les allemands considéré
par ankara comme des paillasses il
disait que on pouvait leur faire faire
n'importe quoi et en plus quand les gens
venaient se plaindre à la préfecture on
leur disait que c'étaient les allemands
qu'édicter les ordres cet après midi
maurice papon a paru quelque peu
déstabilisés par les questions du
président castagnède il n'a pas été en
mesure par exemple d'expliquer pourquoi
la préfecture n'est pas intervenu en
faveur des 14 juil français arrêtés lors
de cette opération qui ne visait selon
les ordres allemands que les juifs
étrangers
l'actualité internationale et coup de
théâtre en algérie le gouvernement
algérien refuse finalement la venue
d'une délégation européenne qui était
attendu dès demain
par ailleurs selon diverses sources
l'ancien numéro trois du front islamique
du salut fis 6 abdelkader hachani a été
arrêté puis libéré cet après midi jérôme
bost dit un ministre des affaires
étrangères très remonté cet après midi à
alger l'algérie refuse de recevoir la
mission de l'union européenne vendredi
premier motif l'europe envoie des hauts
fonctionnaires alger attendait des
ministres et puis il y à ces reproches
tous ces raisons le monde et connaissant
et ils les connaissent
nos amis européens connaissent prend
connaissance et réseaux un des pays
visés et le royaume uni qui préside
actuellement l'union européenne
alger reproche à londres d'accueillir
des militants islamistes et souhaiterait
que le seul objectif de la mission
européenne soit la lutte contre le
terrorisme
ce soir londres n'exclut plus d'envoyer
des ministres à strasbourg on insiste
sur l'urgence de trouver un compromis
il faut faire comprendre aux algériens
que ce n'est pas la fierté de
l'indépendance qui va résoudre le
problème et il y a un problème en
algérie c'est comment assurer la
sécurité des populations
l'enjeu de ces divergences politiques
restent bien cette population algérienne
qui pleure toujours les victimes des
massacres ou plus célèbres dissidents
chinois wei jingsheng récemment libéré
après dix sept années en prison est
arrivé à paris le jour même du 100e
anniversaire du célèbre j'accuse d'emile
zola reçu à la bhl à l'assemblée
nationale le président à laurent fabius
lui a expliqué ce point de l'histoire de
france
wei jingsheng s'est montré quelque peu
désabusé face à l'attitude des
occidentaux qui dit il sacrifie la
morale aux affaires dans leurs rapports
avec le gouvernement chinois richard
binet michel jeannot latos wise inching
applaudi par les députés de l'assemblée
nationale
wei le plus ancien prisonnier politique
chinois
48 ans dont 17 passés en prison sur
l'histoire se confond un peu avec celle
de la chine
1979 la contestation envahi des rues de
pékin
mais le jeune way réclame une démocratie
à l'occidentale et en république
populaire cela se paye cher 15 ans de
prison pour activités contre
révolutionnaires
en 1989 c'est le printemps de pékin
la skin and men les étudiants réclament
sa réhabilitation
mais il faudra attendre huit ans encore
pour signer sa libération
peu après la rencontre historique entre
le numéro un chinois yang des mines et
le président bill clinton
libre wei jingsheng à garder sa liberté
de parole
inutile d'attendre de lui un quelconque
satisfecit même au pays des droits de
l'homme
le citoyen way s'est gardée sont
intransigeantes critique
les gouvernements occidentaux sont très
attentifs à leurs intérêts économiques
même s'il n'exprime pas forcément les
désirs de leurs peuples j'ai
l'impression que ceux qui se battent
aujourd'hui pour la démocratie en chine
sont des empêcheurs de tourner en rond
si wei jingsheng a été reçu ce matin par
laurent fabius à l'assemblée nationale
les portes de l'elysée de matignon lui
resteront fermés ouais il ne pourra y
délivrer son précieux message vous qui
jouissait de vos droits
n'oubliez pas ce qui me ment pas on
compare souvent le dynamisme actuel de
l'économie américaine pratiquement
surchauffé en manque de main d'oeuvre
avec une certaine frilosité notamment en
france il faut se méfier de la
comparaison avec les états unis certes
mais tout de même ce qui se passe en ce
moment dans la capitale du jeu las vegas
donne à réfléchir en même temps qu'elle
donne le tournis par le gigantisme de
ces projets reportage
jean jacques dufour bruno girodon cette
ville de stukas époque où la nuit est
forcément américaine du sepa babylone
revu et corrigé par mickey passat itx
architecture mégalomaniaque las vegas
est en proie à une irrésistible envie de
construire
entre rêve et réalité un mirage dans le
désert c'est comme dans les films assez
très disney un oui c'est très décevant
le clou du spectacle de cet immense parc
d'attractions les hôtels le plus grand
si celui là le mgm
ou de la réalisation 6 milliards de
francs ce nombre de chambres 5000 quant
aux employés ils sont huit mille parmi
les cadres christian bourdelle natif de
grenoble et lavit las vegas depuis 20
ans sur en garde le room-service
observer combien le petit déjeuner à peu
près 2000 2010 les livraisons par jour
c'est un week-end copé à 3005 le
propriétaire de ce paquebot aux
dimensions pharaoniques 45 ha c'est le
milliardaire kirk kerkorian son hôtel il
le trouve déjà trop petit alors il a
fait sonner la charge des grues et des
pelleteuses
il faut aller de l'avant la tour que
vous voyez ici là c'est ce qu'on appelle
chez marriott marquis qui va être une
tour de 1500 chambres qui va
s'additionner avec la mgm vous voyez à
côté de 5000 0,5
donc on aura déjà à peu près 7000
chambres ici on sera dans total de monde
pensait que les gens ici dit nous devons
faire plus grand ou oui un projet qui en
construction à côté du lac sont ils
pensent qu'ils vont et amis méchant
comme on dit chez nous quand le bâtiment
va tout va
ça fait marcher l'économie c'est ça la
construction il y en a pas assez de
d'ouvriers en construction à sega c'est
pour ça qu'ils vont chercher les
ouvriers en floride dans les caves est
est ce que les états unis mais n'y en a
pas assez pour faire toutes
constructions aussi
chaque mois ce nouvel eldorado attire
plus de 5000 personnes
le taux de chômage au moins de 3 en
cours de réalisation le paris casino
et puis aussi le bellagio une petite
folie à l'italienne qui coûtera 7
milliards de francs pour pousser et
contrairement aux champignons dans ce
désert les hôtels n'ont pas besoin d'eau
une pluie de dollars suffit c'est un
terrain de jeu un mirage attrape au
paraguay tropicale en plein désert c'est
forcément un virage
les gens viennent ici pour s'émerveiller
parce qu'ils veulent dire on veut voir
ce qu'ils n'ont pas chez eux pour mettre
plein les mirettes et attirer les
joueurs à leurs familles il ya les
hôtels et puis les parcs d'attractions
ça marche pour 33 millions de visiteurs
l'année dernière pour papa les émotions
du jeu pour les enfants celle du sky
creed
allez-y les poches vides sinon vous
risquez là aussi de perdre nos petites
économies
à propos de l'économie celle de las
vegas de las rien au hasard
le hasard c'est bon pour les bogota pour
les investisseurs ils m'ont devises
le beauf si ça fait pas d'argent c'est
pas la peine de faire ce système
américain in black ou scéniques et
services numériques et pas de limites
donc il ya l'argent on construire des
cellules nord kivu rapporte le plus
d'argent
ici le casino c'est numéro un l'hôtel
numéro 2 en prenant lui revenu et
fournit bearish le troisième nourriture
et boisson rapporte au mgm 125 millions
de dollars plus que l'alcool ce sont les
chiffres qui enivre des sommes
fabuleuses qui permette ait été hilton
et les autres de belle partie de
monopoly au nevada elle se joue avec des
billets verts sur lesquels il est écrit
en dieu nous croyons la coupe du monde
de football selon six mois maintenant
mais la préparation a déjà largement
commencé notamment en matière de
sécurité
aujourd'hui à paris c'est une délégation
de la police anglaise qui s'est déplacé
pour évoquer le problème des supporters
les trop célèbre hooligans pour tenter
de les contrôler liens des policiers
anglais accompagneront ces supporters
entre guillemets pendant leur séjour ou
en france
en effet si le problème des casseurs
dans les stades est en voie de règlement
en angleterre même dès que ses
supporters en ne les traversées manche
et bien ils deviennent incontrôlables
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire londres
etienne dépt
des vidéos comme celle ci les
spécialistes de la brigade criminelle
britannique en décrypte tous les jougs
dans cette salle d'un mètre sur trois le
commissaire chapman emmagasine les
informations et les images tournées par
ses hommes
mais le monsieur anti hooligans du
football britannique
dans les 92 villes où il ya un club de
football professionnel un policier ne
s'occupe que de la lutte contre les
hooligans
ces sommes sont véritablement mes
espions mes yeux mes oreilles ce sont
eux qui font remonter les informations
le dispositif est efficace l'an dernier
4000 personnes filmées par les caméras
de l'unité anti hooligans sont été
interpellé le matériel saisi fait froid
dans le dos des bombes lacrymogènes
jusque aux armes de poing en passant par
le briquet poigne a régulièrement les
appels à témoin son lancer une ligne
téléphonique spéciale est à la
disposition des rapporteurs anonyme
les supporteurs les plus surveillés sont
fichés sur informatique
il ne serait pas plus de 200 en grande
bretagne mais à moins de les incarcérer
on ne peut les empêcher de suivre
l'angleterre à l'étranger s'ils veulent
voyager en france on ne peut pas la
vitesse jusqu'à présent on a l'intention
de changer les lois
mais arrivé avant
pendant la coupe du monde les matches de
l'angleterre seront particulièrement
surveillés des brigades mixtes franco
britannique tenteront de faire la part
des choses entre les supporteurs qui ont
un peu abuser des bonnes choses et les
individus réellement dangereux le
dernier match de l'angleterre à
l'étranger n'incite en tout cas pas à
l'optimisme la cellule anti hooligans
savait tellement prévenu la police
italienne de l'arrivée de 600
supporteurs difficile que les
carabinieri sans doute influencé par la
réputation peu flatteuse des anglais ont
pris prétexte du premier incident pour
engager une véritable bataille rangée
dans les tribunes du stade plus calme la
natation championnats du monde en
australie une médaille d'argent et
quelques regrets tout même pour le
français franck esposito battu d'une
main à peine vous allez voir par
l'ukrainien s'il entière faisant le 200
m papillon une belle deuxième place tout
de même et puis une
deuxièmes médailles en natation
synchronisée cette fois-ci virginie
dedieu déjà médaille d'argent en solo
associé à myriam mignot a obtenu en
double une médaille de bronze christophe
tortora deux médailles en deux jours
cela vaut bien un double coup de chapeau
nous
après de l'argent hier pour virginie
dedieu son duo avec meriem mignot a une
nouvelle fois c'est pis
les deux jeunes femmes ont travaillé
ensemble à peine plus d'un an virginie
est originaire d'aix-en-provence myriam
a grandi en picardie
ce duo nord-sud précède les états unis
et le canada deux pays habitué aux
médailles en natation synchronisée le
podium et l'a totalement différent de
l'or pour la russie de l'argent pour le
japon et du bronze pour la france encore
très beau le championnat d'europe de
patinage artistique à milan une bonne et
une mauvaise nouvelle je commence par la
bonne le couple français abitbol
bernardi très bien placé avant le
programme libre de ce soir en revanche
philippe candeloro est en mauvaise
posture à l'issue de sa première
prestation à milan
yann lavoix exténué mais ravi sarah
abitbol et stéphane bernadis sont enfin
bien placé dans une compétition
internationale tendue 20 jours le
passage du dakar deuxième à l'issue de
ce programme court no 2 français peuvent
nourrir des espoirs les plus fous ce
soir à l'occasion du libre mais pour
décrocher la médaille d'or le meilleur
atout du couple français sera l'audace
ils tenteront en effet tout à l'heure
une première dans le patinage un triple
axel lancé
pour obtenir une médaille candeloro lui
partira de loin de très loin
fâché comme souvent avec son programme
court il n'a pu terminer que 9e cet
après midi
bien sûr quand elles misent énormément
sur son interprétation de ma de
d'artagnan et le podium il est
d'ailleurs encore accessible mais à une
condition il ne doit pas manquer comme
ici c'est triple saut je préfère encore
une fois que ça m'arrive ici aux jeux
olympiques dont c'étaient des petits
réglages de dernière minute qui sont
peut-être pas si mort et à prendre en
france aujourd'hui
l'autre français thierry céret a terminé
16e les juges l'ont tenu pour
responsable de ce petit ennui
vestimentaire une patte du pantalon qui
se déchire et ses espoirs s'envolent mal
barré mais bon comme sa partie de la
jeunesse
il faut considérer ça comme une erreur
de jeunesse même si je veux pas grand
chose pour moi pas de pantalon que
j'espère c'est que
les années qui vont suivre sont
meilleurs pour moi et moins dans l'ombre
de candeloro
oui et de plus perdre ma patte de
pantalon demain les russes pourraient
réaliser un triplé historique yagudin
apte et plushenko occupe à l'issue du
programme court
c'est les trois premières places
martin scorsese le réalisateur américain
a accepté d'être le prochain président
du festival de cannes qui aura lieu du
13 au 24 mai 1998
sorti aujourd'hui toujours cinéma bien
sûr sur les écrans d'un film américain
de oliver stone hughton avec sean penn
oliver stone s'est rendu célèbre déjà
par ses films sur le vietnam sur kennedy
nixon il revient avec une comédie
dramatique qui a pour cadre le désert du
nevada qui dénonce quelques travers de
l'amérique actuelle aubry adler leader
on comprend tout de suite en découdront
supérieur la ville où se situe u-turn
qu'elle est du genre à vous donner des
regrets éternels
tout y allèrent à l'abandon et ses
habitants trop longtemps victime du
soleil impitoyable du désert ont le
cerveau vermoulu ou complètement tordus
pas de chance pour le héros qui à cause
d'une petite panne imbéciles atterri en
enfer rien n'aurait dû le conduire dans
ce patelin
rien ne pourra l'en sortir que jamais la
nouveau disque
à
vous trouvez parfums justement être j'ai
fait beaucoup de voyages je l'aurais je
peux te dire que cette histoire c'est
pas loin de la vérité
ça arrive surtout des gens qui vivent
dans l'isolation est aussi qu'il y a
beaucoup de les mariages consanguins
oliver stone est un réalisateur qui aime
la bagarre celle qui oppose les idées
qui force son pays à revoir son histoire
avec your turn l'air de ne pas y toucher
entre polar et western
il écorne à sa manière l'amérique des
trous perdus ou l'absence de culture
exacerbe la violence la peur et le désir
tchèque
je te croyais à phoenix qui s'assume et
vous vous étiez moi jeune mari ma
violence existe une réalité
je ne cherche pas d'être moraliste sur
ce point parce que je crois que la
violence a toujours là ça va prendre d
autres formes si tu veux mon temps film
ou non se situe le mans bien c'est ça
qui conte supérieur est à dégoûter du
voyage la banque ne rêve pas en sexuelle
on y meurt aussi pas mal mais avec un
humour décapant aussi noir que son fils
oliver stone d'un envie d'un détour et
invente un nouveau style le road movie
immobile me rappelle les titres encore
de ce mercredi d'abord est-ce qu'on
rinne attendu à l'assemblée nationale
sur un point d'histoire traitant de la
sphère dreyfus l'enad jospin apostrophe
l'opposition qui quittent bruyamment
l'hémicycle le gouvernement relance par
ailleurs les zones d'éducation
prioritaire dans les banlieues
difficiles ces établissements ne doit
pas être des ghettos a dit ségolène
royal
le ministre de l'enseignement scolaire
voilà dans quelques instants la météo
sophie davant donc quelques instants
également un film de télévision la veuve
de l'architecte avec michel membre très
beau téléfilm voilà je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur nos prochaines
bonsoir à tous